scientists say they've discovered the
gene for gray hair the research could
pave the way for treatments the stop is
going gray we'll even reverse the
process skies enter Brady reports no
matter who you are or what you do
there's no stopping the aging process or
is there the discovery of the gene that
causes hair to gray could lead to new
ways of delaying or even preventing it
researchers at University College London
analyzed more than 6,000 people of
varying ancestry across Latin America
they looked at seven characteristics of
hair including graying in the hope of
finding new genes among the various
genes they identified was irf4
they knew would played a role in hair
color but for the first time it results
are found to be key in the graying
process if we were able to control that
genetic pathway we might have a way of
controlling hair color or hair graying
hair dresser Ross Poole says 70% of all
his clients want some form of coloring
it's definitely part of the aging
process no one likes to think of
themselves getting older and certainly
none likes to portray that will come
across that way and by covering up the
gray prevents that oh you've got a
little bit older again stigmatism I
suppose so why is it that people worry
so much about gray how would you feel if
one day you did find the gray hair just
know that making right it's the same
thing if I find myself in cause they
know you know it's not something that
worries me and if I'm being brutally
honest I'd rather have more kind of
texture to it
you know the color doesn't really
doesn't really bother me at all in this
day and age with social media being such
a pressure and that sort of thing I
think everybody wants to look as young
as possible and I think that gray hair
is inherently associated with aging so I
think it's just part of a bigger a
bigger question really and just what is
society's problem with gray hair anyway
ageing and all the people as seen as
being perfectly nice and warm and all
the rest but not as very competent and
so I think
gray hair is seen as one of those little
signals that this person might be a bit
less capable a bit less competent than
other people around them who don't have
those signs around 3 million pounds was
spent on temporary coloring products in
the UK last year this discovery could
eventually pave the way for a pill to
prevent grain a Silver Bullet if you
like and a Brady Sky News I've been
making notes on that report let's bring
you the webinar